aujourd'hui j'aimerais partager avec
vous un méthodes que j'ai utilisée
pendant 25 ans quand extrait de
redressement d'entreprises pour les
multinationales et pour les petites
sociétés s'étaient méthodes que j'ai
utilisée aussi bien avec les clients
tout précédemment et qui permettent à
réaliser les résultats par bureau
mais petit mort mais petit secret pour
un grand succès sans vision
comment cette petite salle brel et
continuer dans la première partie
elle vivait ça veut dire que nous devons
fixer un objectif audacieux presley ou
professionnels
beaucoup de gens n'aiment pas ça me dit
souvent que je ne suis pas sûr de
pouvoir y arriver et les deux problèmes
avec ça le premier qui ne risque rien
n'a rien et le deuxième est que vous
pouvez tous beaucoup plus que ça c'est
de vivre pour moi qui dit je suis en
gros je fais encore qu'est ce que vous
pensez
possible
par exemple ne reçoit pas créé un
marathon chaque jour après jour
c'était de 51 en 2008 en 2012 rica 2 1 à
bâle un espagnol il n'a pu briser sarko
quand il a trop bu 607 marronne 11 6 11
7 juin son objectif était de faire 500
marques comme sécurité mais un poids et
chevet pourquoi pas continuer et la crds
ou encore son smartphone de plus on
propre détonnant secteur pendant tout ce
temps rica de travailler en usine
une semaine les jours et en semaines
mais évidemment je ne dis pas que tout
le monde doit se trouver sur huit
marathons
mais je sais que quand tu regardes et
tout ce qu'il a faire c'est vraiment
possible que vous pouvez faire tout ce
que vous pensez donc nous devons viser
haut
parce que c'est les grands objectifs qui
nous offrir les petits objectifs
n'excite personnes on doit avoir un
sentiment d'accomplissement véritable
défi qui nous fait dit que ça serait
formidable tir quand nous avons à la fin
mais j'ai fait un super league rome
objectif être effrayant mairie petit
brun syndicats si vous ne me semble pas
effrayant
ils sont trop petits nous devons avoir
peur c'est bien mais nous devons être
forcée de nous de quitter nos zones de
confort ces zones ne sont pas nouveaux
mais c'est les gens de médiocrité nous
devons vivre mon but mon plus grand
doute objectif prêterait a été fixé par
john elkann était en 1951 qu il n est
pas la fin de cette décennie
nous poserons un homme sur la lune
c'était un objectif
moebius c'était un objectif qui a
inspiré un donnerait semant la nation
est probablement le monde est sûrement
les grands objectifs qui peuvent parfois
et que j'adore ce de cet objectif
c'était la clarté de sa définition
n'était pas juste posé un homme sur le
mais aussi de la ramener en toute
sécurité en afrique je suis seul à rêver
les arts de nantes
souvent mes clients me dis merci nous
fixons un objectif zéro et nous ne
savons pas comment d'y arriver et je
reprends directement que quand jay kay a
inscrit ce but magnifique
il n'avait aucune idée du comment
comment je repère parce que un supérieur
un grand parti de la technologie
nécessaires n'existent départ
donc nous devons viser mais ne soyez pas
trop agressive avec le temps vous
donnez-vous assez de temps pour la
prochaine étape est de commencer a réuni
vers le but est évidemment pour beaucoup
de gens commençaient le parti le plus
difficile pourquoi parce que ils doutent
d'eux mêmes et ou bien c'est dit
nous avons tous deux bois que nous
entendons qui nous empêche confrontait
la bonne route
la première fois c'est un tel un petit
diable que nous avons tous sur le port
qui celui qui dit que nous ne sont pas
faits banques nous n'avons pas ni le
talent ni le temps le deuxième voie
je salue tous les jours autour de nous
qui dit également que nous n'avons pas
le moyen de qui ça ne marche pas que ça
me produirai jamais mais souvent ils
parlent de eux mêmes et pas de nous il
exprime nos propres doutes le propre
père elle nous devons pas laisser notre
potentiel devenez prisonnière d'une
mouche le meilleur moyen pour commencer
elle se montre le doute et de commencer
petit trouver quelque chose que vous
pouvez faire à commencer par la loi
quand j'ai décidé à fait mon premier
marathon à l'âge de 52 ans mais deux
meilleurs amis m'ont dit que je suis
trop bien trop gros et pas en bonne
forme pour le faire et peut-être raison
j'étais 52 ans et 15 km c'était beaucoup
mais j'ai trouvé un programme qui
commence avec 15 minutes de jogging
chaque jour pendant le premier jour le
lendemain j'ai couru quinze minutes
j'étais pas beaucoup s'était passé pour
moi à s'attendre mais c'était un
commencement
nous devons trouver quelque chose si le
prêt à commencer par ça nous devons
trouver quelque chose qui nous libres et
de ceux de ses deux voire négative est
située dans l'un d'eux et schneider mid
soi et non sur notre époque qui dit aux
gens que c'est possible qu'ils peuvent
le faire et que ça va marcher
souvent les clients et aux formes de
passer et ils veulent accomplir leurs
doutes mais le savons comment dire vidéo
il ne savons pas où de commencer et un
bon ami m'a donné des conseils pour
nettoyer après un grand père un des noms
porte par porte mes tailles de descendre
toujours commencer par l'ex l'hiver
exactement pour pouvoir l'écouter
ils ont quelque chose ce patient a
répondu non mais quand ils commencent
toujours par la trouvais ça te donne un
point de départ il ne faut plus
réfléchir ça devient un réflexe et tout
commence automatiquement quand on a
commencé les sors ton chien soon ou du
ventre ou mène au point du départ il
faut passer de la france est à l'action
est le meilleur moyen de faire ça
j'ai trouvé quelque chose partir et
commencé avec ça
prochaine étape c'est ça la vraie je
dois le souligner l'importance de
calibration et le rôle essentiel sur le
chemin de votre succès nous devons
souvent fait qu'ils aient reconnu refait
et nous devons commence à se lever et
reconnaître mais petit succès au début
qu'à three qui nous motive et qui crée
un dynamique positive
et quand je dis j'adore les grandes
entreprises il me dit que je me trompe
et qu'ils attendaient que les besoins
attentes pour le célébrer et si je
demandais et comme bien de grandes
success vous avez célébré dans l'
affaire
il admettait qu on dise entre pas
beaucoup et ça ne me trompe pas puis je
vous demande de réussir souvient comment
et sans réagir quand la vente en a fait
le premier pas tu es tombé sur le
derrière
ils ont dû comme tournant nous avons nos
produits nous sommes réclamées
pourquoi c'est pas craint enfin un
bateau grec aux demandes de son maître
ou acrobates et quand ils essaient de se
justifier en d4
mais seul le premier et je voudrais les
corriger a répété la forte continuer
encore et encore parce que c'est comme
ça que nous apprennent à marcher ensuite
pour est elle même un jour créer un
marathon ce même 38 devrait s'appliquer
à vous même votre équipe si vous voulez
que les gens répétaient la faute
d'où devraient commencer à célébrer n'y
ait pas eu un effort le spleen de soir
elle reconnaissant ce sont deux besoins
fondamentaux et que nous aurons en
corrigeant les gens nous reprendre un
poste et a besoin et nous encourageons à
continuer la fin vous devrez commencer à
remettre le premier enfant
le premier suspect est entré en ce
moment comme ce moment là bas de
reconnaissance la performance suivre
le deuxième pas le dernier parti de ces
méthodes sont simplement de continuer le
plus grande qualité que nous pouvons
développer pour nous mêmes faire la
persistante
pourquoi parce que le système c'est un
multiplicateur du talent est souvent les
grands succès ce sont sûrement en
accumulation de tout succès et c'est la
persistance qui déterminera le trail de
sept succès avec 5 m de l'en-but sais
pas mais j'essaie de me lire et les
augmenter l'effort se répéter
comment je vous fais parce que comme les
gens apprennent que j'écris 1200 un type
solide chiffre donc à fond il me demande
comment c'est possible
ma réponse est simple j'ai écrit un
inclus qui ne prend pas beaucoup
d'efforts mais je le fais depuis
meilleur son
patient c'est pas un seul sac qui nous
qui nous permettent d'atteindre nos buts
ce centre de tous les petits efforts
qu'ils nous donneront la possibilité de
rédiger les grandes choses la répétition
pour améliorer et augmenter la forêt mon
histoire très très du sujet bien des
rixes et veuves qui qui parle d'un
groupe de poterie divisés en deux
groupes
premier groupe maintenant serait basée
sur un piège impeccable deuxième groupe
nom est basé sur le nombre de priest
rodwin premiers groupes jugés à qualité
deuxième groupe pas candidat à la fin de
ce trimestre nous lisons tous ceux
prenant le meilleur produit est fabriqué
par par le premier groupe qui est le ton
but la qualité mais pas le deuxième
groupe qui ont fabriqué beaucoup du port
à améliorer automatiquement il a trait à
actionner la technique entre vallon mais
petit ami les régions peu intéressant de
les petits amis la version qui nous est
d arriver à grandes dents vision car ce
sont les grandes objectifs qui nous
inspire comment s'est trouvé quelque
chose que vous pouvez faire pour
éliminer vos du chalabrais car ce qui
est retenu est répétée et ça criait un
dynamique posture est finalement
continuer parce que la répétition parce
que l'assistance est un motif prêteurs
du talent est souvent les grands succès
son âme accumulation de petits obstacles
vision
comment ce petit chalabrais continue et
au sommet petit secret pour votre
soutien